muchas veces lo más sencillo y lo más
obvio es aquello que por sencillo y por
obvio dejamos de hacer sin darnos cuenta
que es fundamental para nuestras vidas
les ha pasado que de repente deciden
empezar a hacer alguna rutina de
ejercicios digamos que empiezan a correr
o toman la decisión de iniciar una dieta
o sencillamente se van a sembrar algo al
jardín en sus casas
el proceso toma un poco de tiempo quizá
unos primeros diez minutos alrededor de
la cuadra o empezar a hacer ciertos
sacrificios con lo que comemos y
empezamos poco a ver los resultados
500 gramos un kilo o después de semanas
de estar regando el jardín empezamos a
ver que empieza a germinar una pequeña
hojita
uno cuando está en el proceso muchas
veces no es consciente de esos pequeños
cambios
pero de repente llega a alguien que
quizá sin ser consciente de todo el
proceso que llevamos le hace ver a uno
el resultado que se está dando
un poco eso fue lo que me sucedió a mí
cuando me invitaron a que viniera a
compartir con ustedes el tema de que
vengo hablar esta noche
y por supuesto genera un poco de nervios
me dio un poco de ansiedad el saber que
iba a tener la oportunidad y el
privilegio de venir a compartir con
ustedes en un espacio donde gente muy
valiosa y con ideas muy poderosas vienen
a compartir lo que tienen y lo que han
aprendido durante el tiempo
entonces me di a la tarea de empezar a
hacer una pequeña introspección para ver
que lo que habían visto de esto que les
vamos a compartir hoy
y me generó una gran felicidad al ver
que tenía un espacio para venir a
sembrar un poquito de mi semilla en sus
vidas ya compartir en cada uno de
ustedes de esta filosofía de vida que es
sencilla pero que no es fácil y es la
filosofía de ganar dando
ganar dando universe game es un concepto
que desarrolló el doctor ayman master
hace cerca de 35 años
que originalmente fue desarrollado para
trabajar en entornos de grupos de
empresarios donde en espacios de
networking los empresarios se ayudan
mutuamente a generarse oportunidades de
negocio
el tema es muy sencillo si yo le ayudo a
usted y yo le ayudo usted y yo le ayudo
a usted a lograr lo que usted quiere
eventualmente usted va a ayudar a
alguien más y ese animal de ayudar a
otra persona y esa persona otra persona
y en algún momento eso me va a volver a
mí
y bien entendido en espacios
empresariales es brillante
y yo esto lo aprendí hace cerca de 10
años
y al entender cómo funcionaba empecé a
aplicarlo a otras áreas de mi vida y de
esta manera es que hoy vengo a compartir
este concepto y esta filosofía con
ustedes pero quiero dejar algo muy claro
yo no soy nadie extraordinario no tengo
una inteligencia excepcional no tengo
habilidades diferentes simplemente soy
una persona ordinaria que hace un
esfuerzo extraordinario para que todo lo
que haga genere un impacto y una
oportunidad para un mejor mañana para mí
mi familia mis amigos y mi comunidad y
esto me es importante compartirlo con
ustedes porque así como muchos si
tomamos la decisión podemos empezar a
ser conscientes y hacer cambios que
generen este impacto
y para compartir un poco que no soy nada
especial nada diferente quiero
compartirles un poquito sobre mí este mi
familia y papas tico mi mamá gringa eso
yo esperaría y quisiera decir que mejoró
la raza pero no sé qué tan qué tan
cierto pueda ser el concepto
de mi papá siempre he dicho que tengo en
la parte amigable y pura vida de los
ticos y un gran espíritu de lucha mi
mamá viene de una línea militar muy
marcada y de ahí considero que tengo de
del lado gringo esa resiliencia y el
pragmatismo de la vía en el ejército mi
papá siempre fue empresario mi mamá
siempre ha sido mamá que para mí es la
profesión más admirable que existe y el
máximo ejemplo de ganar dando que hay en
la vida
mi familia es una familia de clase media
no acomoda nunca nos faltó nada pero yo
siempre quise más y eso quizá mal
enfocado podría ser algo no tan positivo
para mí sencillamente me dejó ver hacia
dónde quería ir y la bendición y la
oportunidad que me dieron mis papás de
estudiar en un colegio privado fue tener
una excelente formación un excelente
aprendizaje
y ver con otras personas hacia dónde era
el norte que quería marcar en mi vida
personalmente me considero empresario a
lo largo de mi vida y quizás por ejemplo
mi papá he desarrollado diferentes
proyectos entre los cuales tuve una
agencia de publicidad por 15 años pero
mi negocio o empresa más importante de
mi familia la cual fundé hace casi 11
años y resultado esto tengo tres
hermosos hijos ariana sara y felipe que
ellos me cambiaron a mí la perspectiva
del mundo porque sé que muchos aquí
siendo papás cuando están solteros y sin
hijos quieren comerse el mundo pero una
vez que tienen hijos se dan cuenta que
quieren que el mundo sea totalmente para
ellos y con esto cierro ciertas ideas
que para mí han sido elementos
fundamentales de cómo de la vida y cómo
me comparte cómo me comporto alrededor
de ella y es que primero
siempre he pensado que el ser humano por
naturaleza es egoísta
2 que el ser humano siempre quiere más
3 que el ser humano como el agua buscará
siempre el camino de menor resistencia y
4 si hay algo en esta vida que no nos
gusta tenemos que ser conscientes que
probablemente es algo que primero
tenemos que cambiar en nosotros
y esto es de las cosas más difíciles que
debemos empezar a comprender y haces esa
introspección
y realizar que no podemos seguir
justificando nos que es que yo soy así
porque así era mi familia yo soy así
porque así fui educado o decir
sencillamente no es que yo tengo 40 años
siempre he hecho las cosas de esta
manera y nada me va a cambiar como ser
humanos como seres humanos tenemos la
capacidad de tomar esa conciencia
podemos tener un poquito de humildad
poner el ego de lado y darnos cuenta que
debemos de tener un proceso que quizá no
es positivo para nosotros en la vida
y aquí les cuento una pequeña historia
en los primeros años de la agencia un
día me llama a una de las mejores amigas
de mi novia en ese momento ahora es mi
esposa no quiero ningún momento y como
ahorita pero me llama y me dice steven
estoy fundando mi agencia de diseño
gráfico
quisiera ver si me puedes ayudar a
establecer el esquema de costos y el
esquema de precios para empezar a captar
clientes pongamos el contexto mi futura
competencia me está llamando para
pedirme a mí que le enseñé la fórmula
que yo he ido trabajando durante los
últimos 34 años que me ha costado
muchísimo y ya quiere que sencillamente
yo se lo dé
vean no quería ayudarle
se acuerdan que les compartía que la
naturaleza del ser humano es ser egoísta
esa era la prueba contundente de esto y
qué feo que alguien que confía en mí me
llama y me pide que le ayude yo
sencillamente evadía las preguntas y no
quería colaborar
y cuántas veces y en cuántas cosas
nosotros no nos comportamos de esa
manera
cuántas veces le negamos la ayuda a
alguien para compartir nuestro
conocimiento o nuestro talento porque
sentimos que vamos a perder algo
quién es el que realmente gana cuando da
una ayuda
la persona que recibe la ayuda o las
personas que dan ayuda
el tema acá es que nosotros estamos
programados para el intercambio
hemos sido educados en una cultura donde
para nosotros el principio el concepto
es el de ganar-ganar por lo menos si no
es que ganó solo yo pero jamás estamos
educados para un concepto de ganar
perder
pero qué tal si cambiamos el chip y nos
damos cuenta que el concepto y el
negocio es ganar dando y aquí entramos a
lo que sería la construcción de una
cultura de colaboración porque realmente
para todos hay oportunidades cada uno de
nosotros será especialista en diferentes
áreas y el colaborar con alguien que
tradicionalmente vemos como una
competencia realmente es un colega y es
una persona aquí nosotros podemos ayudar
a que prospere ya que le vaya bien y si
nosotros ayudamos a otras personas otros
empresarios a que les vaya mejor el
resultado en sociedad y en economía es
que todos vamos a ir mejor y aquí la
clave es saber que le estamos educando
nosotros a nuestras futuras generaciones
les estamos enseñando a que ellos tienen
que ser competitivos y buscar ganar o
darse cuenta que es más negocio si
colaboramos entre nosotros
muchas veces es muy sencillo ser
indiferente
pero realmente es tan sencillo ayudar
que no nos damos cuenta el poder y el
impacto que tenemos nosotros como
individuos en el espacio que tenemos
alrededor nuestro y no nos damos cuenta
como nosotros realmente podemos influir
en esa área
cuando nació ari mi hija mayor y empieza
su transformación interna cuando uno es
consciente de la responsabilidad que
tiene en el futuro de esta criatura y en
el futuro de lo que ella va a tener
empecé con esa ansiedad esa preocupación
de cómo hacía yo para cambiar el mundo
un planeta con 7.7 billones de
habitantes y yo un individuo como hacer
un cambio y empiezo con esa frustración
y creer que no voy a poder hacer nada y
iphone de que hay en cuenta en otras de
esas conclusiones personales de lo que
yo llamo mi metro cuadrado y que es mi
metro cuadrado el área inmediata a la
que yo tengo alcance
todos todos somos agentes de cambio y
todos podemos impactar de manera
negativa o positiva a nuestro entorno
yo personalmente elijo impactarlo de
forma positiva
desde como trato a mi esposa como trato
a mis hijos como trato a mis
colaboradores en la empresa cómo
comparto con los empresarios con los que
colaboró con la gente que tengo a mi
alrededor
desde ahí yo puedo impactar de forma
positiva a que ellos empiecen a darse
cuenta que este comportamiento y esta
manera de desenvolverse es más
productiva para nuestro entorno y aquí
si logramos empezar a hacer que todos
seamos conscientes de eso lo que
empezamos a lograr es una suma de metros
cuadrados que empiezan a crear una
plataforma que nuevamente en nuestra
sociedad generan mayores oportunidades
mayores beneficios y mayores momentos y
espacios agradables para todos los que
estamos en esa sociedad y ahí es a donde
yo quiero hacer este planteamiento y
entender de qué se trata el concepto de
ganar dando
hemos sido educados bajo un principio de
reciprocidad
la reciprocidad como un concepto dentro
de psicología social es el resultado
donde ante una acción positiva recibe
una respuesta positiva la reciprocidad
es tan antigua que se hace referencia a
la misma en el código de hammurabi donde
se plantea que el comportamiento de un
individuo debe ser en beneficio de la
sociedad o de la comunidad
pero el concepto de ojo por ojo también
es un reflejo directo de la reciprocidad
y lo que se resume aquí todo está dado
por intercambio
si yo doy algo espero algo a cambio
mi planteamiento es
ayudar y ayudar y ayudar sin esperar
nada de vuelta
y miran bueno pero
cuál es el chiste cuál es el chiste si
yo estoy ayudando a otro si a mí no me
da nada pues justamente esa es la magia
porque si nosotros vamos por la vida
contando favores y las ayudas que les
vamos dando a las otras personas
la carga se nos va a ser muy pesada y no
vamos a poder disfrutar el viaje
ganar dando es un tema actitud de ser
conscientes de como nosotros podemos
ayudar y colaborar con la gente que
tenemos alrededor
ganar dando se trata de responderle una
llamada o una solicitud de ayuda a un
colega incluso a alguien en competencia
que considera que nosotros tenemos las
respuestas y les podemos colaborar
pónganse a pensar el honor que significa
que alguien lo llame a una a pedirle
ayuda por qué no hacer esa colaboración
ganar dando empiezas desde la sonrisa
que le pueda dar a una persona en la
calle
desde atender esa llamada a un amigo que
nos pide su colaboración desde ser
conscientes que esto no se trata de una
inversión de dinero necesariamente una
inversión de tiempo reitero es una
cuestión de actitud
eso sí ganar dando no es un
comportamiento que yo tengo sobre un
tiempo corto
un comportamiento que yo he decidido
tomar y accionar por el resto de mi vida
hay un químico en el cerebro que resulta
del fenómeno de dar y ayudar a otros y
en la liberación de la oxitocina y la
oxitocina se conoce como el químico del
amor que es lo que siente uno cuando
tiene relaciones sexuales o cuando una
madre a pecho un hijo
es un sentimiento de calor de euforia
empatía y sucede cuando nosotros
ayudamos a los demás
imagínense que todos fuéramos
conscientes de empezar a ayudar a otros
entraríamos todos en un viaje de
oxitocina que lo que haría sería
desencadenar un efecto virtuoso donde
todas las personas están ayudando y es
que nosotros buscamos ese sentimiento de
bienestar y eso se da sencillamente al
ayudar a otros y no nos cuesta nada
es simplemente una cuestión de tomar
conciencia de adoptar esta actitud
a mí me preguntan si espero ganar dando
funciona por supuesto que funciona ley
natural si a mí me tratan bien yo voy a
tratar bien de vuelta pero debemos dejar
de esperar ese intercambio y regreso
debemos de empezar a hacerlo porque nos
nace porque nos placer
hace unos días
y va a un evento en el colegio de mi
hija al cierre de bimestre la actividad
era la una de la tarde e íbamos llegando
1252 venía con mi esposa la pareja y
calp ya vamos llegando al colegio y de
lejos se ve que hay un montón de carlos
ya parqueados afuera eso significa que
el parque adentro está llenísimo
me acerco al portón bajo el vidrio y
saludo al oficial de seguridad que
siempre ha estado en los últimos cinco o
seis años
víctor todo bien
si jon stevens todo bien está muy lleno
adentro hay que pulsar la
me dice si está llenísimo no pasa nada
tranquilo voy a ver dónde parqueo me
dicen steven esperes un momento
esto me espera un momento se va
caminando y le dice al chofer de uno de
los buses del colegio que está
estacionado al frente algo
donde esté bien espere su momento
estaciones lo aquí
víctor no tenía por qué hacerlo lo hizo
porque él nació lo único que ha pasado
es que durante los últimos cinco o seis
años yo lo saludo todos los días algunas
veces me he tenido a conversar con él sé
un poco cuál es su historia
qué cosas quiere hacer que le mueve que
no le mueve
en algunos momentos he procurado
ayudarle pero eso ha sido todo nunca lo
he hecho buscando nada a cambio y él eso
no lo hizo buscando nada a cambio pero
es el resultado de un acto de un hábito
de una repetición
y con esto cierro con una pequeña
conclusión
esta cuchara para qué sirve
para que lo usamos normalmente
la respuesta esperada es para comer
este cucharón para que usamos
normalmente
para servir normalmente usamos más la
cuchara y nos beneficiamos nosotros
mismos escucharon que es para servir a
los demás
entre más usemos el cucharón para
beneficiar y ayudar a los demás más nos
estaremos ayudando a nosotros mismos
porque de esta manera al servir a los
demás más tendrán todos en su plato para
que todos podamos comer entre más
ayudemos a otros más nos ayudamos a
nosotros mismos ganar dando es una
filosofía de vida para un mejor mañana
muchísimas gracias
[Aplausos]